i am so curious had you been talking to
marvel
about doing something at marvel prior to
moon night um or was this sort of did it
all happen with moon knight you know
there have been a few dances in the past
there have been a couple parts that i
wanted
or was interested in that they weren't
interested in me for and they approached
me about some other parts that i
didn't feel like i could be successful
in
and
and this one just felt right
i don't know part of it had to do with
the fact that i was already a fan of
muhammad's work and so i trusted
muhammad i think he was really talented
guy and
and the fact that
i knew that oscar was biting off so much
it was it was a huge opportunity slash
challenge
for oscar and he
really wanted
me involved in it and i felt like that
voted well for us to have a good
experience because i really like his
work and the way that he thinks and
attacks a role uh was right in line with
mine
and so i i had a sense that we'd have a
good time together uh yeah you guys are
kind of good together i'll say it like
that you know i just i don't want to
inflate the ego
yeah please don't right yeah
but i really like your portrayal and i
like that he is not like over the top i
like the the delivery of the voice um
can you sort of talk about uh finding
like your look and your voice and for
the character
you know i hadn't been in a marvel movie
but i'm a fan i love comic books and i
love
all kinds of genre movies and
the more you study them
the more the you really come to realize
that a hero is kind of lives in
opposition to their villain right that
the hero's journey happens because of
the villain the villain makes the hero
in a way and so i knew i had to work in
tandem with oscar so if he was going to
be
uh like the moon
and multi-dimensional and ever-changing
and inconstant then i needed to be
constant if he was unbalanced i needed
to be balanced if he was broken with
sharp edges i needed to be soft and
gentle
uh
it's just it kind of
you know that was going to help the
whole story turn
and
i felt
that if he was insane i needed to be
sane and that was a challenge like how
do you
how do you present somebody who's
completely sane who's malevolent you
know and i started really
seeing him as a
kind of uh cross between a monk and a
doctor you know part carl young
uh
studying him caring for him
uh and like this monk who had this
benevolence to them but
i
i find you know when you take somebody
who believes they're spiritually
enlightened uh and make them
have a
kind of darker undercurrent a sinister
undercurrent i find those characters
really creepy you know nurse ratchet for
example in cuckoo's nest she's so clean
and careful and kind and terrifying
because whenever anybody knows exactly
what sanity is
you start to feel insane around them
uh
so
that was how i how i built him
and
i just took
different aspects of
i created him out of something that i
thought would be a good foil
for a a fractured mind yeah it totally
works um i already have to stop i'm just
gonna say uh thank you so much for your
time and i can't wait to see episodes
five and six well me too so wish you all
the best thanks man thanks for
everything
thank you sir take care of that cat
you